hello and welcome to this video playing
em western yep we have played a couple
of noodles I guess don't quite remember
how it how it panned out have a slightly
positive score against them let's see
what we get yeah against this I've tried
a couple of things d 5 is a good
continuation but I've also have
experimented with d6 and e5 which is
probably not objectively best but and
it's too interesting play so I'm going
to give it a go um what here 96 I can
need to be at kind of Kings Indian I
don't know this is any good I can take
play nights at six let's do that I mean
just experimenting you a little bit the
most a solid way to plane also what I've
got in my book is 75 but no harm in
trying out things once in a while ok so
what is this is g6 an idea yeah looking
at the default porn shouldn't be bad we
should be five I have to go h6 I guess
yeah he's a bit worried about 94 things
like that quite understandable decision
ok um defy this interesting here trying
to stop his t 5 i'm going to do that
it's interesting move if you take second
97 capture regaining the porn like that
okay so how do i get my met bishop out
here that's an issue hi Scott could
control the f5 wonder if b6 is some kind
of IDM to this looks a little bit like
an elegance other kinds defense I cannot
pronounce the name i'm sorry about that
a little bit okay let's go for that I
have my doubts have to admit but let's
see what happens my idea is to take and
then play Bishop 86 to develop that
Bishop so let's go for it and Bishop a4
might be might be tricky though mm-hmm
can be a pretty awkward pin okay I'm
still let's shoot for that for Bishop 86
I mean I'll put it here yeah Bishop a4 I
want to go Queen to d7 and as I said
this is quite awkward but I don't see
how he increases the pressure on that
night I don't like to do that it feels
wrong but I had no big choice at the end
so doesn't get much more pressure that
Bishop f4 could be a move for Queen f4
or something like that maybe here
doubling on the e-file and maybe I can
actually move the Queen Quincy 1886 that
could be an IDM
now putting pressure on c7 here okay
maybe let's trade one rope here
now I actually have some stuff on the d4
pawn maybe ok I'm going to take here and
we have reevaluate now I'd love to unpin
this it really looks like a bad idea to
stay in that pin for a long time so
let's go back maybe shoot for Quinn to a
six it's not so bad if the Queen comes
to a 6 i'm going for night f4 here i can
actually move the night now this is
quite quite interesting to note maybe
just do this cover the five and have
root a six up my sleeve it's a bit
strange but maybe it's not so bad it
feels a bit unnatural what I'm doing
here Oh c6 makes a look look really
silly
and maybe just 96 0 what is this loop
doing now sacrificing will move it again
and then I wouldn't be surprised if
there's some kind of big drawback to my
play
I was the thing I didn't have a great
idea with 96 just attacked the rock okay
um Knight to f5 may be okay if I've kun
86 but to do that I need to improve my
background now he's shooting for rugby
8i have Queen f5 though not sure how bad
this is maybe Queen to be seven or
something like that okay bishops it too
was not a move I saw so right
unfortunate and it's got some pressure
on g6 now have to be quite who quite
careful time warning yeah I know in my
rook and my rook
don't see a move I simply don't see a
movie and I have six isn't well yep I
didn't see a move it's just as simple as
that now I don't want to trade but what
else oh my goodness what a bad position
men whoop Dee 7 oh my god I was a
terrible game really terrible game
Rosella yeah I really don't know what
what happened here now maybe I was kind
of okay at some point but I don't know I
was wow really hated this yeah I putting
myself into that self pin just very
inconvenient I don't like this kind of
thing my computer is still not hating my
position but it just just looks wrong
now here could have one already by
taking a plane queen bee to when he
catches me on the back rank yeah just
rubbish game just a rubbish game yeah I
shouldn't really should really stop with
playing something like experimental and
stuff like that usually experimental
meets [ __ ] I mean this is not so bad
but yeah there's really no need to go
into anything anything weird that feels
wrong somehow to Knight a5 skin by the
comb that's actually interesting move
trying to go to c4 and not allowing any
kind of pinning business I was tempted
by getting the bishop out of the chain
and covering t5 like that but it is
actually not doing much in
this pin is just awkward yeah I mean
maybe here this is not so terrible
objectively speaking but I absolutely
hated the position right here what does
the engine giving this is the kind of
move this engine move this is a kind of
move somewhat place that against you you
know it's a computer no human being
place that move in a blitz game this is
actually saving black isn't that funny
this losses but here look b6 amazing I
mean okay saving 0.3 or something at
least the game continues what a move
yeah the computer gives this as the best
launcher yeah yeah I'm really completely
alive and just 0.2 or something amazing
which mean see pair to do something else
look before yeah anyway this is the
normal human move and my position is
just absolute rubbish now yeah I'm just
lost him yeah I decided it's really hate
this way I played this probably I should
just not do stuff like just this and
black is okay this is the normal move
and tier white is absolutely nothing
yeah but it's also not very interesting
that's the same time still I should do
that just play normal classical chairs I
not do anything out of the ordinary this
is what I should have done anyway thanks
for watching